emmanuel macron aime se rendre à
l'étranger pour rappeler que la france
est un acteur géopolitique de premier
plan dix neuf ans après jacques chirac
le voilà qui s'envole ce lundi pour les
pays baltes enfin plus précisément pour
la lettonie et la lituanie l'estonie ne
faisant pas partie de son plan de visite
s'il se rend là-bas ce n'est pas par
courtoisie ou pour parler économie la
question biélorusse est au coeur de
cette visite les pays baltes attendant
du président de la république qu'il
montre un peu l'exemple sur l'attitude
que doit adopter l'union européenne face
à la crise politique dans ce pays voisin
du leur tout comme les pays baltes lieux
n'a pas reconnu l'élection d'alexandre
loukachenko
quant à la lituanie elle a même donné
refuge à ce fait la nati canucks callas
figures de l'opposition biélorusse est
qu emmanuel macron pourrait rencontrer
les trois états baltes ont décidé de
mesures à l'encontre de fonctionnaires
biélorusses jugés responsables de la
répression contre l'opposition
bruxelles devrait également bientôt
décider des sanctions contre minsk pour
l'instant bloqué par un veto de chypre
récemment ce fait la nati canucks kaya a
déclaré au journal le figaro qu'elle
attendait beaucoup d' emmanuel macron et
espérer que ce dernier s'engage pour
aider à sortir de l'impasse s'engager
certes mais comment espère tel qu
emmanuel macron accélère le processus de
sanctions économiques contre la
biélorussie qu'il joue peut être un rôle
de médiateur entre lukashenko l
opposition
l'elysée dit réclamé une transition
pacifique avec la fin de la répression
puis par l'engagement d'un dialogue
prenant en compte la volonté de la
population je cite en évitant le risque
d'une plus grande répression voire une
intervention de la russie même si moscou
n'a à aucun moment fait quelques
mentions que ce soit d'une intervention
il vaut mieux prendre les devants
surtout que la france possède un compte
argent de 300 soldats stationnés sur la
base lituanienne de roeck là dans le
cadre de la présence régionale renforcée
de l'otan l'otan aux portes de la russie
un contingent français qui se fait
passer en revue par le président lors
d'une période de troubles politiques
dans un pays allié de moscou
le président de la république qui
rencontre une opposante
on dirait qu'il se prépare quelque chose
dans la région